the tears come easy
was a fighter
she knew he could die any time she
promised him she won't cry
promise she had to break
Sean
what was I going to do break his legs to
stay home what future awaits them many
of his friends were killed by Israeli
forces now he followed in their
footsteps
just before the Israeli assault on
Janine in the occupied West Bank she
messaged to me so he can come home
his answers would frustrate her but now
she says she'll never forget them in a
bit mother I just left the camp I will
sit in a coffee shop and come back home
this picture was widely circulated
amongst Palestinians in the past few
weeks told his mom it wasn't him
now the family believes it was his
cousin Rena keeps his picture on her
pendant
we are proud of him some wrote poetry
about that picture
this is not a life that we're living
once you travel then you see how people
live how they think but here we feel
like we live in a cage
semi has one of 12 Palestinians killed
by Israeli forces during the two-day
military operation the longest in 20
years Israeli forces have killed more
than 100 Palestinians from Janine since
last year and as the bodies keep piling
up the cemetery inside the refugee camp
is full so people here have set up a new
place to bury the victims of Israel's
most recent assault
side by side and one by one they laid 11
Palestinians to rest
Israel's prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has said this won't be the
last operation in this refugee camp
which means it won't be long before more
Palestinians are buried in this new
graveyard
Ibrahim Al Jazeera Janine the occupied
West Bank
well as Nita was just alluding to
Israel's prime